yes Sonia this was the first time I
pointed a camera at Professor Martin
Polyakov back in 2008 through year under
a jumper it seems I've been filming him
ever since for me meeting someone so
passionate about his subject brought
back memories
so think back to when you were at school
as a schoolboy in Australia I've been
fascinated by science
meeting the professor led to a crazy
idea let's make a video about every
single chemical element all 118 of them
that I should look at you well nor the
camera we called it the periodic table
of videos a few weeks later we filmed
our first elements a test of endurance
rather than anything let's give it a go
so welcome to our periodic table videos
hydrogen is the lightest element number
2 helium so helium is probably the most
unreactive of the elements number 3 um
so lithium is the lightest metal no
script just an almost encyclopedic
knowledge of chemistry so potassium is
very reactive one of my colleagues who
used to work with it described it as
evil
wicked potassium is very important
bodies contain quite a lot of potassium
it's in all sorts of biological material
if you burn garden rubbish in the ash
that you get in the end is potassium
which is presumably why it's called
potash but even professors have their
limitations and Martin's seem to be at
number 108 what's the next element
assume I know nothing about her soon
should we make something up
luckily colleagues want men to help Debi
K's that's that's history biochemist
which probably isn't very good
Steve little walk
Neil Barnes Oh Samantha Taine's a 50-50
mix of the two five four and the
explosive Pete license one that was more
like lovely but the frizzy-haired
professor was the projects heart and
soul and you can imagine the periodic
table bit like a family photograph we
soon realized we had a youtube hit on
our hands
Martin became something of a celebrity
in demand for newspaper interviews at
home and further afield then a cameo on
America's CBS News for all his
celebrated work as a research chemist
and university professor Martin Polyakov
didn't become a celebrity till he got on
the Internet
I know a lot of people who aren't
interested in science and as soon as he
pops up on the screen and starts talking
people just look and listen I really
enjoy making the videos because I enjoy
talking to the viewers and also finding
simple ways of explaining things I
suppose I've learnt a bit of how to
present things and much more critical
now when I see people on television I
get really cross when I think they've
spent too much money on the series and
think what we could have done with
similar funding emails from fans were
flooding in more and more teachers were
using the films in schools these
youngsters in New York even quizzed
their online hero hi professor Michael
it is is it aluminum or aluminium
because I wouldn't know what to call my
aluminium model hi it's a great model
and you should call it aluminium but it
was here in India that I realized the
professor had achieved cult status for
the chemist I would like to give him
lifetime he's been terrific day I'm very
excited pretty tired
everyone wanted my photograph even the
chef was photographed with me from the
restaurant why do they want you
photograph because I look so silly of
course by now we had exhausted the 118
elements but the net was cast wider I
only expect it to be quite so Wow after
all everything's made of chemicals
there's seventeen point nine eight grams
so this is more than enough to make over
three hundred standard tablets of Viagra
now I'm not going to open it because
after that none of my male colleagues
would want to come into my office as the
videos evolved the professor has opened
up more about his own life made films on
personal subjects such as the sad
passing of friends and colleagues and to
drink a toast to the memory of Tony he
may look the stereotypical scientist but
Martin's anything but a cold analytical
researcher and just to say to all of you
that it's very important whoever you are
to remember the people that helped you
as a child and made you what you are
today then last year a special accolade
for the professor he was appointed
foreign secretary of the Royal Society
the lead role in the Royal Society for
making sure that the Royal Society and
science in the UK is recognized and
promoted internationally and he is
forging links and
and is generally helping to promote
collaborations between UK scientists and
other scientists around the world it's a
fantastic mark of achievement for Martin
we're all incredibly proud of him and
we're all we wish him the best of luck
in the position and hope that well he
can he can go forward and make changes
to science on the global scale and now
the YouTube viewing figures had soared
into the millions so let's try and see
what happiness something we'd never
dreamed of on that first day in June
2008 nothing may happen because it's an
old sample but let's have a look are you
ready go
the periodic table of videos had gone
global we're in Sydney Australia so here
we are on the summit of the Corcovado
and behind me is the famous statue of
Christ the Redeemer
so when dum starts internally where they
made six different super-heavy elements
and I'm just going to show you how they
did it in a surreal twist the professor
even appeared in the Guinness Book of
Records the world's smallest periodic
table edged on one of his hairs we could
get a million of those periodic tables
onto one of these post-it notes they'd
been meetings with Nobel Prize winners
we'd even won a few prizes ourselves
it's made a new discovery it's a new
element it's called a war diem it's been
a wonderful exploration I never have
done any of that without the videos but
for me it really became personal when we
both made a trip to Australia between
lectures and a bit of sightseeing we
made a visit to my hometown of Adelaide
and dropped it on my old school where
perhaps the seeds were sown for this
whole crazy endeavor this is the varied
periodic table that Brady set looking at
and they've still got the same periodic
table and amazingly still here was my
teacher who inspired me almost twenty
years ago some may be out there called
donkey orchid Martin have a look at this
blue orchid what a stunning beauty hey
two men from opposite sides of the world
both igniting a passion for chemistry so
how do you actually inspire your
students what do you do that makes them
I don't I do nothing except what's in me
already I am fascinated by science I'm
I've got a passion for for young people
and and and science and all those things
that make life possible and maybe maybe
that has rubbed off now I don't know
what's next for the periodic videos and
I'm not sure the professor does either
your mind is a bit like soup it has to
be stirred up all the time and then
interesting vegetables float to the
surface and so on but from my side of
the lens it's already been an amazing
journey
you